most people know that you can melt ice  just by putting salt on it salt  decreases the melting point of the ice  meaning it'll melt faster what's another  way to decrease the melting point of ice  the answer is you apply pressure to it  tonight I want to do an experiment on  regulation regulation means you apply  pressure to ice and so it turns into  water but when that pressure is removed  it turns back into ice I have two pairs  of 1.5 kilograms weights this pair is  joined by a bit of fishing line and my  other pair is joined by some copper wire  they're both the same thickness now I'm  going to put the wire and the fishing  line over this block of ice and try to  pull it through the ice and I want you  to make a prediction which one will pass  through the ice first will it be the  copper wire or the fishing line or will  they both pass through at the same rate  make your prediction now you got about  five seconds left quick pick one that's  too late